participez à l'amélioration du cadre de
vie générer du lien social contribué au
vivre ensemble ce sont les principes
essentiels pour qu'un projet soit retenu
par la mairie de villepreux la ville
lance son premier budget participatif
avec une enveloppe de 25000 euros ça
faisait partie des engagements de
campagne de la liste villepreux
naturellement dont l'équipe municipale
est issu donc pour nous c'était
essentiel de mettre en place cette
promesse aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de confiance et de défiance envers la
politique et au niveau local en tout cas
si on peut par par le respect de la
parole donnée aux électeurs contribuer à
renforcer ce lien de proximité entre les
élus et les habitants mais on est
heureux d'y contribuer santé jeunesse
sport transition écologique les
habitants ont jusqu'au 15 mai pour
déposer leurs idées au total quatre
projets seront retenus je trouve que
c'est une bonne initiative
dès l'instant où on fait participer les
citoyens quels qu'ils soient dans quel
domaine que ce soit ça me paraît une
bonne initiative j'étais pas au courant
comme je vous le dis mais enfin bon
priori oui c'est une bonne initiative ce
qui serait bien à mon avis
et c'est qu'on fasse un peu plus pour
les jeunes je trouve qu'il ya pas assez
d espace où les jeunes peuvent se
rassembler peuvent s'amuser peuvent
prendre du temps voilà alors que c'est
vrai que les structures sportives et
existe
mais tout le monde n'y a pas forcément
accès moi j'appuie sur une chose c'est
que ce serait vraiment pas mal de
d'utiliser ce budget pour les activités
des enfants les idées foisonnent
lorsqu'on va à la rencontre des
habitants la ville de villepreux a déjà
reçu quelques dossiers alors on a des
projets qui devraient arriver notamment
sur l'éducation et la jeunesse on sait
que c'est des thématiques qui sont qui
sont fortes en ce moment donc on n'a pas
le détail précis des projets encore et
on sait que ça devrait être ça devrait
être des thématiques publicité par les
porteurs de projets les villes provient
et les villes proviennent peuvent
déposer leurs idées par mail ou par
courrier à la mairie pour proposer son
projet c'est simple il suffit de remplir
ce formulaire disponible à l'hôtel de
ville ou sur le site internet de
villepreux nom du projet objectifs
thématiques les dossiers seront ensuite
étudiées par la ville puis voté du 17 au
27 juin